[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
- une équipe municipale c'est avant tout
une famille car on passe des moments
très forts ensemble et je voulais
profiter de ce temps de parole pour
remercier mon équipe
merci bravo c'est vous qui me donne l
énergie de me battre chaque jour pour
défendre nos projets nous avons une
équipe qui est à l'image de guyancourt
c'est à dire riche de par sa diversité
nous venons d'horizons politiques
différents mais nous nous rejoignons
tous sur le même projet qui est de
donner un nouvel élan à guyancourt
[Applaudissements]
nous souhaitons nous aider les uns les
eaux et le bien vivre ensemble alors
s'entre aider les uns les autres c'est
la solidarité
c'est à dire que nous reverrons le
budget du ccas afin de venir en aide aux
plus démunis
nous souhaitons changer de direction en
termes de parcours résidentiel c'est à
dire de favoriser l'accès à la propriété
et ne pas laisser les gens locataires
avis et nous pensons également ou dix
ans courtois et qui me une part pas en
vacances l'été en leur proposant et
guyancourt plage afin que que de les
enfants les adultes où tout le monde se
retrouve autour d'un dans l'événement
festif l'été pour le vivre ensemble
en fait c'est redonner vie à notre ville
nous allons développer la démocratie
participative notamment via les conseils
de quartier nous allons relocaliser les
habitudes de consommation en faisant la
promotion de nos commerces locaux et
nous allons lutter contre les
incivilités et notamment les rodéos qui
gangrènent la vie des lions courtois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
notre première décision sera de
retravailler en retour à la vie normale
le rôle d'un maire c'est d'être à
l'écouté et d'être agile en cas de
changements tels que nous les avons
vécues récemment
donc nous allons créer une cellule post
crise sanitaire qui va regrouper tous
les acteurs de la ville de gueugnon
cours que ce soit au niveau économique
social commerce éducation les seniors la
sécurité la santé la famille d'isolement
social le handicap tout le monde pour
envisager ensemble le jour d'après
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]